bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat 2 ans après la signature des
accords de Bery le Sénat examine le
projet de loi relatif à la rénovation du
dialogue social dans la fonction
publique ce texte est en effet la
transcription législative de ces accords
signés le 2 juin 2008 entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats et dont
l'objectif était de renforcer la
représentativité des organisations
syndicales mais également de renforcer
la place du dialogue social à noté que
ce projet de loi a été élargi au statut
des infirmières la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat a donc été
saisie pour avis tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle bonne séance à
tous allez nous reprenons la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée relatif à la R
inovation du dialogue social et
comportant diverses dispositions
relatives à la fonction publique dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'article
2 à l'amend l'article 2 monsieur le il y
a pas d'amendement je consulte du regard
la Haute Assemblée nous considérons
comme adopté après l'article
2 un amendement du Gouvernement monsieur
le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est un
amendement qui sécurise la possibilité
pour les agents qui consacrent la
totalité de leurs servicees à l'exercice
de leur mandat syndical donc de
bénéficier des mêmes garanties
d'avancement et de promotion que les
fonctionnaires qui relèvent du même
corps ou cadre d'emploi et qui sont en
service dans leur administration il
s'agit d'éviter simplement que la
promotion de tels agents puisse être
assimilé à une nomination pour ordre sur
le fondement de l'article 12 de la loi
du 13 juillet 1983 le fonctionnaire
bénéficiant d'une décharge d' activité
pour l'exercice d'un mandat syndical
demeure en position d'activité
l'activité syndicale n'est pas
détachable du service les représentants
des personnels ayant vocation notamment
à siéger dans les organismes
consultatifs chargé d'examiner les
questions d'organisation et de
fonctionnement des services en l'état
actuel de la jurisprudence il y a un
doute qui subsiste sur la possibilité ou
non de promouvoir un agent qui exerce un
mandat syndical à temps complet sans
qu'il soit contraint de cesser ce mandat
contrairement à l'agent qui exerce ce
mandat à temps partiel donc pour les
droits au but et pour toutes les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer rien ne justifie
qu'il soit établi une différence entre
les personnels bénéficiant d'une
décharge d' activité partielle et qui
pourrait donc le cas échéant rejoindre
pour partie leur nouvelle affectation et
les personnels investis d'un mandat
syndical à temps complet dans ce
contexte le présent amendement ne fait
qu'offrir la possibilité à
l'administration qui le souhaite de
promouvoir un agent compte tenu de ses
talents et mérites indépendamment de
l'exercice par celui ici d'un mandat
syndical alors Monsieur Jean-Pierre Vial
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la commission saluons
respectueusement monsieur le président
de la commission des lois oui monsieur
président cet amendement sécurise la
faculté de promouvoir un agent investi
deandat syndicale à temps plein en
écartant dans ce cas l'interdiction des
nominations pour ordre contenu d'une
part de la nature du mandat en cause au
service des syndicats
constitutionnellement protégé et d'autre
part de la faculté de promouvoir des
délégués syndicaux à temps partiel fus à
90 % il s'agit effectivement d'une
mesure d'équité c'est un avis
favorable qui demande la parole mes
chers collègues si plus personne ne
demande la parole je mets au voix à
l'amendement 114 du gouvernement que
ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter veuillez
bien le manifester en levant la
main merci avis
contraire il y a pas d'avis contraire
ben il en est ainsi décidé allez à
l'article
Mame maton oui mais il y a
personne bon l'amendement 57 de Madame
maton poana mais je vois personne pour
le défendre donc il tombe l'article 3 y
y a-t-il des observation sur l'article 3
dans ce cas-là je le m au voix que ceux
qui sont d'avis d'adoptter Veez bien le
manifester en levant la
main avis contraire il y a pas d'avis
contraire il en est ainsi décidé al
article 4 monsieur Maas amendement
25 alors monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui augure d'une longue
discussion
concernant le
paritarisme alors nous entamons donc ce
premier amendement qui vise pour nous
socialistes à préserver le paritarisme
le projet de le moi met fin au caractère
paritaire des trois conseils supérieurs
et des comités techniques paritaires je
voudrais revenir quelques instants sur
ce qui fonde notre attachement à ce
paritarisme le paritarisme est est
corollaire pour nous du dialect social
il est tout se tout simplement in
concevable qu'un projet de loi portant
rénovation du dialogue social supprime
le paritariste il y a ici une
contradiction grave entre le contenu du
projet de loi et son titre je le dis
avec conviction et j'aurai l'occasion de
le répéter au cours de nos débats pas
trop j'espère il faut préserver le
paritarisme dans la fonction publque je
voudrais commencer par évoquer celui qui
nous tient le plus à cœur à savoir le
cas de la fonction publique territoriale
dans la fonction publique territoriale
le paréarisme s'impose comme une
évidence il y a près de 5 6000
employeurs territoriaux il faut
absolument prendre en compte cette
diversité certes l'article 10 prévoit
que seul l'obligation paritaire
disparaît mais que le paritarisme pourra
survivre dans les fêes cela dépendra des
élus mais cela ne suffit pas en effet
l'article 11 prévoit que le recueil de
la vie des employeurs territoriaux
intervient de façon distinct du recueil
de la vie des représentants des
fonctionnaires cet article supprime donc
la possibilité d'additionner les votes
des deux collèges du Conseil supérieur
de la fonction publique territoriale il
faut être très clair à ce sujet si les
votes des membres des collèges
employeurs et représentants du
personnaire ne sont plus additionnés
l'opposition s'en trouvera muselée
certainement le but mais enfin il n'est
pas avoué il n'est pas rare que les élus
de l'opposition non majoritaire au sein
du collège employeur souhaite voter
contre les projets de la de la majorité
ne pas permettre l'addition de ces vote
à ceux des représentants du personnel
c'est s'assurer que les positions des
élus de l'opposition ne pourront jamais
s'exprimer car la majorité ne sera
jamais atteinte ce mécanisme est
d'ailleurs également prévu pour le
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique hospitalière à l'article 16 du
projet de loi nous nous y posons bien
sûr aussi j'enviens maintenant au cas de
la fonction publique d'État nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire qu'il n'y a
qu'un seul employeur dans la fonction
publique d'État l'état est-ce une raison
pour supprimer le paritarisme je ne le
pense pas l'article 6 supprime le
paritarisme au sein du Conseil supérieur
de la fonction publique d'État autrement
dit seuls les représentants du personnel
prendront part au vote bien entendu le
dialogue devient par définition
impossible enfin l'article 8 du projet
de loi supprime le paréarisme dans les
comités techniques de la fonction
publique d'État et l'article 13
l'amoindre considérablement dans les
comitons techniques de la fonction
publique d'État là encore nous ne
pouvons que regretter la disparition de
ce qui fait l'essence du dialogue social
le dialogue entre employeur et personnel
d'ailleurs cette disparition semble bien
curieuse compte tenu du fait que le
paritarisme est maintenu au sein des
commissions administrative paritaire j'y
voilà une contradtion et je vous invite
donc à à adopter mon
amendement alors quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président je remercie
notre collègue d'avoir fait je dirais à
l'occasion de cet amendement une
approche globale du du paritarisme donc
euh je crois que je procéderai de la
même façon en répondant globalement pour
n'avoir pas y revenir et je pense que
Monsieur le Ministre fera de même
puisqueeffectivement on se trouve au
cœur d'un des des objets de de de de
cette réforme en ce qui concerne le
paritarisme nous l'avons longuement
évoqué notamment en ce qui concerne
celui de la fonction publique
territoriale avec ce choix possible
monsieur le ministre ne manquera pas de
de revenir sur ce point et puis c'est
était effectivement dans la discussion
un aspect de veiller à ce que cette
représentation et et ce ce dialogue
puisse être maintenu être maintenu et
notamment c'est toute la discussion qui
concernera plus
particulièrement le Conseil commun
puisque nous avons veillé à ce que les
fonctions publique notamment la fonction
publique territoriale puisse garder une
une représentation une une expression de
de ces positions dans ce conseil commun
alors en ce qui concerne en revanche cet
amendement je dirais que à l'encontre de
cette présentation globale l'amendement
est satisfait par le texte du projet de
loi pour pour cet amendement numéro
25 concernant l'alinéa 7 et c'est donc
un avis défavorable pour cet amendement
comme il le sera d'ailleurs globalement
pour l'ensemble des amendements visant
la préservation du paritarisme et l'avis
du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président l'
vie du gouvernement est le même et la
démarche va être la même que celle du
rapporteur c'est-à-dire que je vais
redonner monsieur Mayas qu'il connaît
bien le point de vue premièrement il ne
s'agit pas en gros de supprimer le
paritarisme il s'agit de l'aménager dans
la fonction publique de l'État c'est
clair c'est précis on a une logique qui
conduit l'administration à présenter le
texte et en même temps le voter il y a
aucune valeur ajoutée à la fonction
publique hospitalière tout cela
fonctionne depuis longtemps notamment
dans les comités techniques
d'établissement ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne bien il y a rien à rajouter
reste le problème monsieur Mayas le sait
bien qui est celui de la fonction
publique territoriale avec ses 25000
55000 pardon employeurs on a eu une
discussion à l'Assemblée qui nous a
conduit à aménager le texte et je crois
très sincèrement que l'on peut tout dire
sauf qu'il n a a plus paritarisme dans
la fonction publique territoriale je
répète ou je redis ici je vous prie de
m'en excuser mais c'est important de le
faire au moins une fois les éléments de
cet aménagement en premier lieu le
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale continuera à
fonctionner sur la base de deux collèges
le collège des employeurs et le collège
des représentants des personnels il y a
donc identification précise des deux
deuxièmement le Conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique territoriale pourra
demeurer composé d'autant d'élus que le
souhaite le collège des employeurs en
3oème lieu les avis de chacun des deux
collèges continueront à s'exprimer à
travers un vote et les voix des
employeurs et des représentants des
organisations syndicales c'est là une
différence effectivement ne seront pas
additionnés chaque collège assumera donc
ses positions ce qui est essentiel au
pluralisme et qui en plus nous paraît
concourir tout naturellement à la
transparence 5èmement les comités
techniques pardon ainsi que les CHSCT
pourront fonctionner sur le même schéma
que le Conseil supérieur comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure monsieur le sénateur
dans la discussion générale et comme je
le répète ici nous avons donc une
logique est une logique simple précise
qui consiste en réalité a donné la
faculté dans les collectivités qui le
souhaitent de pouvoir décider du
paritarisme numérique c'est une faculté
qui remplace une obligation et très
franchement vous l'avez vous-même cité
ce chiffre tout à l'heure le fait
d'avoir 55000 employeurs publics fait
queon n'est pas obligé d'imposer une
obligation qui peut-être légèrement
décalé par rapport à tout cela quant à
ce qui concerne l'amendement numéro 25
dans le même esprit que pour les trois
autres conseils supérieurs de la
fonction publique la nouvelle instance
ne sera pas composé paritairement il
s'agit là d'un des points forts des
accords de Bery que nous souhaitons
respecter l'objectif ne doit pas être en
effet de parvenir à un nombre égal de
représentants mais à une représentation
équilibrée de toutes les parties
présentes prenant pardon dialogue
sociale interfonction publique c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous émettons un
avis
défavorable qui demande la parole
explication de vote si plus personne de
demande la parole je mets au voix
l'amendement 25 notre collègue monsieur
Maas que ce qui sont d'avis d'adopter
bien le manifest
la avis
contraire
l'amendement n'est pas' adopté alors un
amendement 26 de Monsieur Maas monsieur
le monsieur le monsieur le monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre cet
amendement vise à donner au président du
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale membre de droit du
Conseil commun de la fonction publique
la possibilité de prendre part au vote
je crois qu'il s'agit là que d'aller
jusqu'au bout d'un mouvement initié par
le rapporteur je vais donc revenir sur
les différentes étapes du travail
parlementaire don l'amendement que je
présente me paraît l'aboutissement
nécessaire
la version initiale du projet de loi ne
prévoyait pas la présence du président
du Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale au sein du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publ le Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique a été
renommé comme conseil commun de la
fonction publique suite à l'adoption
d'un amendement du groupe SRC adopté en
commission à l'Assemblée le groupe SSRC
a ensuite défendu en séance sans succès
la présence du président du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale au sein de ce conseil
commun au Sénat la commission a adopté
un amendement du rapporteur prévoyant
cette présence malheureusement
l'amendement ne prévoyait pas la
participation aux délibérations pourtant
et nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire la fonction publique territorial
comporte près de 60000 employeurs c'est
ce chiffre qui conduit à dire que
l'expertise du président du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale doit se traduire par un
vote au sein du Conseil commun de la
fonction publique par ailleurs comme
tout employeur le président du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale doit pouvoir avec voix
avoir voix délibérative au sein de la
nouvelle instance consultative cela
participe n la préservation du
paréarisme quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur dans le texte en vigueur le
président du sfph est un Conseil d'État
est un arpit qui conduit les débats du
conseil sans participer au vote le texte
de la commission reproduit le système en
vigueur c'est donc un avis défavorable
et du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est le
même avis que le rapporteur pour les
mêmes raisons explication de vote
monsieur monsieur le main dans ce cas-là
je mets au voix l'amendement de notre
collègue monsieur le main que ceux qui
sont Davis d'adopt veuille bien le
manifester en levant la main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
alors nous en arrivons à un amendement
27 toujours de Monsieur le main ou de
Monsieur
Maas le
monsieur le
Président cet amendement vise à assurer
le parétarisme au sein du Conseil commun
de la fonction publique donc je ne vais
pas répéter ce qui ce qui a été dit mais
ce dialogue social vise quand même la
recherche du consensus et je voudrais
quand même rappeler certains propos du
ministre du travail lorsqu'il a
présenter le texte à
l'Assemblée monsieur a affirmé le
gouvernement a voulu rechercher ine
profonde de la proportion à privilégier
les conflits souvent stérile au
détriment d'un dialogue constructif le
conflit n'étant pas un mode de
négociation
moderne donc je je pense que à ce moment
là le mode de négociation moderne c'est
exclure le dialogue
bon c'est un petit peu compliqué et donc
monsieur je cite de nouveau les propos
de Monsieur jusqu'à présent le di social
resta marqué par le formalisme source de
confrontation plus que de discussion
entre employeurs et représentant des
agents donc on cet amendement propose de
mettre en œuvre une réelle discussion
entre employur et représentant des
agents seul un vol commun peut permettre
cette discussion le formaliste ce serait
justement d'organiser des votes séparés
par collège j'ajoute qu'on ne peut se
satisfaire que la avis des représentants
des employeurs de l'État et leurs
établissements publics ne soient plus
recueillis ENF je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le projet de loi
concernant le dialogue social dans les
TPE qui a été examiné cette semaine par
la commission des affaires sociales un
amendement du rapporteur a supprimé la
possibilité de créer les futures
commissions paritaires au niveau local
encore une fois on voit bien le peu de
cas que le gouvernement fait du dialogue
social la terminologie employée ne
résiste pas à l' des
textes
alors il y a un deuxième
amendement attendez oui mais j'ai pas
tourné à ma page 59 de Madame matampona
oui merci monsieur le Président
théoriquement à l'issue de l'examen de
ce projet de loi un conseil commun de la
fonction publique devrait être créé en
complément des trois conseils supérieurs
propres à chaque versant de la fonction
publ pour éviter que ces derniers
n'examinent à tour de rôle les mêmes
textes et afin de favoriser le dialogue
interfonction ce conseil devrait être
saisi de toute question d'ordre général
commune aux trois versants sur l'emploi
sur la
mobilité voilà l'ambition sousagante de
l'instauration d'une telle instance est
donc de créer un lieu de négociation
commun à toutes les fonctions publiques
et toutefois en même temps qu'il le crée
cet article limite considérablement la
portée de de la viis du Conseil commun
enfin selon ce texte l'avis du Conseil
de la fonction publique sera rendu
lorsque l'avis des représentants des
organisations syndicales des
représentants des employeurs publics
territoriaux et des représentants des
employeurs publics hpitaliers aura été
recueilli ainsi l'avis du Conseil commun
exclura d'une part l'avis des
représentants des administrations et
employeurs de l'État et d'autre part
sera segmenté par type de représentat
donc nous pensons queun tel système ne
peut pas permettre un réel dialogue le
Conseil commun risque de rendre des avis
qui ne seront qu'une compilation des
trois conseils supérieurs alors qu'il
devrait être le résultat d'une réelle
négociation entre eux c'est pourquoi
nous proposons que les avis du conseil
de la fonction publique soient le
résultat d'une négociation collective de
tous les représentants plutôt qu'un
assemblage sectoriel des différentes
positions quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur je
revois je
demain concernant l'amendement 27 il
s'agit d'amendement contraire au texte
de la commission qui a retenu le système
du vote par collège au sein du Conseil
commun c'est donc un avis défavorable
c'est le même avis défavorable pour le
59 et l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre sur les deux amendements merci
monsieur le Président il est défavorable
de fois car dans le même esprit que que
pour les trois autres conseils
supérieurs de la fonction publique la
nouvelle instance de dialogue ne sera
pas composée de manière paritaire il
s'agit d'ailleurs d'un des points forts
et importants des accords de berc le
fait que cette instance ne soit pas
composée paritairement ne fera pas
obstacle à l'expression de l'ensemble de
ses membres les représentants des
employeurs territoriauxx et hospitaliers
auront comme les représentants des
organisations syndicales voie
délibérativ le vote par collège permet
de structurer qualitativement les
positions de chacun afin que les points
de vue des uns et des autres soient
mieux pris en compte dans le débat c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous souscrivons
pas aux amendements B explication de
vote dans ce cas-là je mets d'abord au
voix l'amendement 27 de Monsieur Maas
que ceux qui sont David adopté veuillez
bien le manifester en levant la
main merci avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté j'imagine
que c'est le même vote pour le
59 allez même vote même vote il en est
ainsi décidé à l'article 4 je ne suis
saisi
d'aucun attendez oui excusez-moi je mets
au voix l'article 4 ainsi modifié ou pas
que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter vez
bien le manifester en levant la main
merci avis
contraire l'article 4 est adopté alors
au chapitre 2 sur les dispositions
relatives à la fonction publique d'État
sur l'article 5 il y a il n'y a pas
d'amendement pas d'amendement je
consulte du regard la Haute Assemblée il
n'y a pas d'opposition s'il y a pas
d'opposition nous le considérons comme
adopté à l'article 6 un amendement 28 de
Monsieur
domaiselle attendez laissez-le parler
quand même il arrive à
peine monsieur le Président merci de
faire remarquer que je d'abord faire
prendre la parole je pu porter
témoignage que vous êtes spécialiste de
toutes ces questions je vous remercie
qu'est-ce que je suis gentil avec les
socialistes
moi ça devient ça devient
douteux merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la Linéa 3 de l'article 6 prévoit que
seuls les représentants des
organisations syndicales seront appelés
à voter au sein du conseil supérial de
la fonction publique de l'État bien
entendu les sénateurs socialistes ont
une autre conception tout autre de ce
que doit être un un dialogue social
surtout nous ne transformons pas
arbitrairement le sens des mots un
dialogue c'est un échange ce ne va de
soi bien sûr on va m'oser qu'il n'y a
qu'un seul employeur dans la fonction
publique de l'État je le répète cet
argument ne fait pas le poids face à la
nécessité de préserver le dialogue je
suppose que l'on va également m'oser le
cas des comités d'établissement dans la
fonction publique hospitalière qui ne
sont pas paritaires je réponds d'avance
cela n'a aucun rapport on ne peut pas
répercuter automatiquement les
mécanismes prévus pour une partie de la
fonction publique sur une autre partie
de cette fonction publique sans voie
délibérative la participation des
représentants de l'administration au
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique n'a plus aucun sens vous en
conviendrez c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous serez tous d'accord pour
voter cet amendement numéro 28 alors sur
l'amendement 60 de
Madame merci monsieur le Président cet
article 6 supprime le paréarisme au sein
du Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique de l'État se faisant il impose
que nous posions quand même la question
de la pertinence de cette suppression
comment témoignent les accords de ber
les organissance syndical ont appelé de
leur vœux une évolution de la
représentation de l'administration au
sein des organes consultattif
destiné en fait à la rendre plus
efficace et la plus légitime possible
pour échapper à la critique du
formalisme certes mais contrairement à
ce que vous avez prétendu monsieur le
ministre les organisations syndicales
n'ont pas souhaité l'abandon pur et
simple du paréarisme et cet abandon ne
constitue pas un axe important des
accords berc il constitue tout au plus
un axe important de la réforme qui nous
est soumise donc les organisations
syndicales signataires des écords on
pris acte des faiblesses d'un
paritarisme trop formaliste mais ce
nifit pas pour autant qu'il faille
totalement revenir sur cette modalité de
composition du Conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique de l'État et une
composition paritaire assure l'existence
d'une confrontation de point de vue le
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique d'État ne doit pas devenir
qu'une simple instance d'enregistrement
des doléan des représentants des
organisations syndicales mais doit
rester tout de même un vrai lieu de
dialogue et d'échange des opinions et
d'adoption d'ailleurs de positions
communes on ne peut quand même pas
dialoguer sans interlocuteur c'est quand
même un peu difficile donc nous déposons
cet amendement pour rétablir cette cette
parité monsieur le
rapporteur connaître votre avis sur le
28 et le 60 oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur Maas fait tout à l'heure une
intervention globale considérant qu'on
avait évoqué définitivement le le du
paritarisme et Monsieur demisel
effectivement intervenant reprend les
explications pour le rapporteur il ne
peut qu'en rester il ne peut qu'en
rester à la position qui tente à faire
remarquer qu'on par ses amendements on
tempant à réinttroduire l'obligation du
paritarisme c'est donc un avis
défavorable idem pour l'amendement 60
alors l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
j'ai expliquer en discussion générale et
tout à l'heure pourquoi j'étais
évidemment contre le principe de ces
amendements donc c'était favorable deux
fois explication de vote dans ce cas-là
je mets au voix l'amendement 28 de
Monsieur domoiselle que ceux qui sont
avis d'adopter veuilleent bien le
manifester en levant la main merci avis
contraire merci l'amendement n'est pas
adopté même vote pour le 60 je consulte
du regard la Haute Assemblée pas
d'opposition
adopté n'est pas
adopté pardon allez nous en arrivons à
l'article 17
rectifié et ben il y a aucun des
protagonistes là il tombe et le 29
monsieur monsieur Mayas ou Monsieur Le
Men allez monsieur
mayas et cet amendement vise à préserver
le caractère paritaire des comités
techniques tout simplement je n'aie pas
autre chose à rajouter il s'agit d'un
amendement de coordination de notre part
je ferais quand même simplement
remarquer que disons nous allons avoir
trois commissions trois blocs
là au niveau de l'État là au niveau de
l'Hospitalier et et l'autre au niveau
des communes et ce sera trois
représentations différentes dont l'une
pour les communes au gré des élus voilà
nous sommes en train de de de faire des
règles différentes pour une fonction
commune où on voudrait qu'il y ait des
passages facilités d'une d'une fonction
commune à une autre je sais pas si c'est
le meilleur des solutions vous êtes en
train de faire ça merci Monsieur Maas
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues le dialogue pour vous ça se
cantonne à ce qu'il y a un nombre égal
de gens qui s'opposent
les uns vis-à-vis des autres en fait
c'est ça mais oui mais oui c'est ça
parce que quel est l'important mais
attendez monsieur vous me permettez
Monsieur Mayas je vous ai écouté avec
patience et
attention je pense que le dialogue il y
a des propositions faites notamment au
niveau de l'État il y a il y a des
représentants de l'État qualifiés pour
défendre ces propositions il y a un
dialogue avec les syndicat il y a les
propositions faites pourquoi voter en ce
qui concerne l'état c'est donc aux
organisations syndicale de faire
connaître leur avis c'est ça un comité
technique alors pour les pour les
collectivités qu'on est offer une
souplesse moi je trouve monsieur Mayas
moi je suis très attaché à la fois au
fait qu'il y a un socle commun de la
fonction public et c'est comme ça qu' a
été construit d'ailleurs les lois de 83
84 et cetera et puis des spécificités
selon les collectivité il est évident
que dans les collectivités locales vous
avez cité le nombre d'employeurs et
d'illeurs d'ailleurs vous me permettrez
de vous dire que les 55000 n'ont pas
forcément un comité technique paritaire
parce que les petites collectivités
c'est au niveau des centres de gestion
que se règle les problèmes en général
hein c'est pas au niveau de chaque
collectivité il y a des villages qui ont
deux agents trois agents il y a pas un
comité technique bon donc je crois que
garder cette spécificité c'est pour ça
qu'il y a une différence moi je trouve
ça tout à fait normal mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que pour avoir moi
présider des centaines de réunions de
comités techniques paritaires dans une
collectivité locale dans un
établissement public service d'insendie
en fait l'intérêt c'était le dialogue
entre le représentant le le le maire ou
le président de l'établissement public
accompagné d'un certain nombre de
sachant je dirais parce que bon et puis
avec les organisations
professionnelles pour discuter de tous
les sujets qui étaient nécessaire de
discuter mais c'est pas le vote qui
était important je dirais même par
contre il faut savoir s'il y a une
majorité de représentants du personnel
qui adhère aux propositions et pour moi
le paritarisme c'est ça mais c'est pas
nombre pour nombre c'est complètement
parce que souvent on cherchait comme
vous dites vos vos élus de l'opposition
qui votaient différemment je trouve que
c'est pas cohérent parce que d'abord
c'est le maire ou le président de
l'établissement public ou le président
du conseil général qui est le chef de
l'administration c'est lui qui fait des
proposition et moi
inversement dans ma collectivité j'ai
des collègues qui sont dans l'opposition
ils votent toujours avec du côté de de
du président du conseil général même
s'ils sont pas toujours en accord parce
que il considèrent que ça fait un bloc
que le le représentant le représentant
de l'administration le maire ou le
président du conseil général et bien il
est suivi par les élus et et donc le
fait qu'on soit en nombre qu'on soit 3
contre 7 ou c'est pas ça qui est
important c'est que le dialogue se
construise et je trouve que franchement
ce débat me paraît complètement
surréaliste et on nous obligeait bien
bien souvent on on disait on va pas
voter parce qu'il manquait un
représentant de l'administration des
choses comme ça franchement mais si mais
si Monsieur Maas on pouvait jouer ces
choseslà franchement je pense qu'on a
mieux à faire et que le dialogue dans la
fonction publique c'est pas parce que il
y aura le même nombre les uns en face
des l'autres des autres que le dialogue
s'établira au contraire quand il y a la
position des organisations
professionnelles face à des propositions
et le dialogue c'est qu'on fait évoluer
les propositions aussi c'est pas vous
allez voter ou vous n'allez pas voter
dans les collectivités local moi j'ai
toujours vu ça que on pouvait faire
évoluer les choses on fait des
propositions on discute ça dure
quelquefois de longues heures et on
aboutit à quelque chose qui est commun
et je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
profitable c'est tout à fait dans
l'esprit permettez-moi de vous le dire
de des accords de Bery et je ne
comprends pas cet attachement au
paritarisme qui est purement formel et
qui n'est pas la réalité de ce qui se
vit dans les comités techniques tous les
jours alors nous en arrivons à
l'amendement 61 de Madame maton
poana il est défendu monsieur le
Président sur le paritarisme j'
reviendrai pas je ferai ai plaisir à
Monsieur yes bien que je
ne suive pas tout à fait son avis je me
tiens mon très bien plus personne
demande la parole mes chers collègues
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur pardon sur le 29 et le 61
oui vous l'avez compris monsieur le
Président qu'il s'agit d'un avis
défavorable sur ces deux amendements
pour les raisons longuement exposées et
le gouvernement monsieur le ministre la
même chose pour les mêmes raisons
monsieur le Président dans ce cas-là je
mets au voix l'amendement 21 de Monsieur
monsieur Maas explication de vote si
vous voulez bien sûr non parce que je
voudrais quand même répondre un tout
petit peu à Monsieur
si dans certaines collectivités locales
les choses sont bloquées et que c'est un
semblant de de de discussion pourtant
vous privilégiez la discussion ce n'est
ce n'est pas vrai partout ce n'est pas
vrai partout il y a bien
évidemment disons des des discussions
qui qui sont disons plus
consensuelles bien sûr bon donc donc un
maire qui qui
disons à dans ce type de commission une
opposition et qui part une discussion
quelquefois les les les votes ne se font
pas et quand on les additionne c'est
beaucoup mieux en disant bah
l'opposition votera d'une façon
démagogique avec les les les syndicats
pour ambter la municipalité ça se fait
pas comme ça enfin je crois que vous
vous pensez qu'il y a des gens qui sont
pas responsables bon et à partir non
mais attendez ça se fait peut-être comme
ça chez vous ça se faisait peut-être
comme ça autrement chez moi ça se fait
pas comme ça bon et et quel est quel est
le gros avantage c'est que vous avez un
contact entre des élus municipaux et je
prends cet exemple là ce que je connais
mieux hein et et puis des représentants
syndicaux c'est un plus dans une
municipalité c'est un plus dans une
municipalité ça je peux je peux je peux
en témoigner et et et par là même tenez
je fais le Paris
puisqueon nous donnera la possibilité
effectivement le paritarisme dans dans
les collectivités territoriales et
notamment les communes et bien je vous
fiche mon billet qu'il y aura un très
grand nombre de communes où on
maintiendra le
paritarisme bon c'est plus personne donc
c'est l'inverse qu'il fallait faire
c'est-à-dire donner la possibilité qu'il
n'y ait pas de paritarisme que le
paritarisme était la règle notamment
dans les collectivités dans les
communes dans dans les collectivités
territoriales mais qu'on pouvait on
aurait pu en discuter si on avait fait c
invers cette inversion mais c'est pas ce
que vous avez fait au démarrage au
démarrage d ah on supprime le
paritarisme et et je prends acte bien
évidemment que vous êtes revenu sur
cette position et et c'est un plus ça je
vous l'accorde et ben monsieur le
ministre puisque vous demandez la parole
oui merci monieur Président je la prends
rapidement simplement pour dire à
Monsieur ce que nous avons déjà eu ce
débat en commission il y a effectivement
une question de choix soit on prend
comme règle la rigueur soit on prend
comme règle la souplesse nous on choisit
de prendre comme règle de référence la
souplesse vous choisissez ce que je
respecte profondément une règle qui est
une règle qui est un peu un carcan qu'on
oblige chacun à suivre si vous prenez le
texte du Gouvernement c'est la souplesse
que l'on choisit rien vous l'avez dit
vous-même d'ailleurs j'ai noté que
c'était une une avancée rien n'empêche
une commune rien n'empêche une
collectivité de décider le paritarisme
on propose la souplesse c'est le choix
du gouvernement
Monsieur M se souvient aussi de la
phrase d'dard r un bon discours
quelquefois fait changer d'avis jamais
de
vote allez je mets au voix l'amendement
29 de Monsieur Ma que ceux qui sont Dav
adopté ve bien manifester en levant la
main merci av
contraire merci aussi et l'amendement 61
de
madame vote même vote
allez alors l'article 6 pas de
d'amendements donc nous
considérons comme adopté alors nous en
arrivons à l'article 7 pas davantage
d'amendement je consulte du regard pas
d'opposition il en est ainsi décidé
l'article 8 allez amendement 63 de
Madame maton
poana monsieur président mais là là
c'est un peu la même chose j'ai déjà
exprimé un peu pourquoi nous voulions la
représentation du personnel dans les
organisme tels que les groupements
d'intérêts public il y a eu déjà un
amendement à ce propos donc nous avons
la même
position pas d'autre
intervenant avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
oui effectivement comme le fait
remarquer président de la commission des
lois cet amendement tombe dans
normalement en tout état de cause il est
lié à la position des GP dont on a
longuement débattu tout à l'heure ça
serait donc s'il ne tombe pas une
demande de retrait et de du gouvernement
monsieur le
ministre exactement le même que celui de
la commission pour les mêmes raisons
monsieur le Président Madame pr vous
vous retirez votre amendement vous
voulez que je le mette au vo je le mets
au voix que ceux qui sont d'Avid adopté
veillent bien le manifester en levant la
main merci avis contraire l'amendement
n'est pas adopté alors
numéro 30 de Monsieur
Mayas am de coordination aussi et le 62
de
Madame même chose allez avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur avis déforable du
gouvernement défavorable aussi Monsieur
le Ministre
merci même vote allez je très bien même
vote même vote pour les deux est ainsi
décidé les amendements ne sont pas
adoptés le
22 ben le 22 il tombe l'article 8 je
mets au voix l'article 8 que ceux qui
sont d'avis adopt ve bien le manifester
en levir la main Monbar merci avis
contraire
allez l'article 8 est adopté à l'article
8 bis un amendement
65 de Madame maton
parfaitement l'avis de la commission
quand même monsieur le rapporteur pour
faire les choses en règle défavorable et
du gouvernement défavorable monsieur
président jeamais au voix que ceux qui
sont en d'adopter veille bien le
manifester en levant la main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
à l'article 8 bis il n'y a pas
d'amendement je consulte du regard la
Haute Assemblée pas
d'opposition adopté l'article que 9
amendement 66 de Madame
tompoanafendu
aussi même avis de la commission même
avis de la commission même avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre très
bien dans ce cas-là même vote aussi
allez il en est ainsi décidé et
l'article 9 est
adopté après l'article 9
euh bon madame mat allez madame matomo
vous vous dévouez pour le
CRC des affaires sociales euh les
personnes en situation de handicap
peuvent bénéficier dans certaines
condition de dérogation aux règles
habituelles d'accès à la fonction
publique principalement au concours la
loi de janvier 1984 modifiée pourant
statut de la fonction publique d'État
prévoit donc un mode de recrutement
spécifique pour les personnes
handicapées à afin de faire en sorte que
les fonctions publiques d'État
hospitalière ou territorial contribu
aussi comme dans les entreprises du
secteur privé à l'insertion par le
travail des personnes en situation de
handicap ce mécanisme prend la forme
d'une contractualisation directe avec la
personne handicapée à condition que
celle-ci puisse se justifier de niveau
de qualification professionnelle
concernant la catégorie qu'il entend
intégrer la règle étant qu'à l'issue de
ce contrat si l'agent a fait preuve des
aptitudes professionnelles requises à
l'exercice de ses fonctions il est
titularisé or en l'état actuel du droit
la fonction publique parlementaire ne
connaît pas de règles dérogatoirees elle
est la seule fonction publ à ne pas
participer directement aux efforts
collectifs réalisés pour permettre
l'accès à l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap et ce alors même
que les deux assemblées qui la composent
participent activement à la définition
des politiques publiques en matière de
handicap et d'emploi en particulier donc
vous en conviendrez tout de même qu'il
s'agit d'une situation quelque peu
curieuse et que dans dans laquelle se
trouve l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
que d'ériger des règles normatives et de
refuser les appliquer à nous-même c'est
pourquoi c'est d'autant plus surprenant
qu'il s'agit d'une loi de société au
caractère hautement symbolique si cette
dérogation au principe du concours que
nous avons défendu existe c'est pour
permettre à des hommes et des femmes
meurtris par la vie de trouver leur
dignité dans le travail et la place dans
la société à laquelle ils ont droit et à
laquelle ils aspirent
il s'agit donc d'une disposition
législative au caractère humaniste que
nous proposons au Sénat euh pour
fairecienne d'ailleurs 15 ans après son
adoption ici même et enfin je rappelle
que cet amendement ne nécessite aucune
dépense supplémentaire puisqu'il a
effectif constant nous proposons que sa
mise en œuvre se fasse en concertation
bien évidemment avec le personnel du
Sénat et nous proposons donc de remédier
à cette situation et d'appliquer la
fonction publique parlementaire les
mêmes règles que celles qui sont
applicables aux trois autres fonctions
publiques alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président il s'agit
effectivement d'un amendement dont on
voit bien le contexte qui vient d'être
évoqué qui vise deux dispositions le
problème le premier c'est celui du du
statut des agents des assemblées le 2e
c'est bien évidemment la mise en œuvre
de la loi de 2005 sur le handicap cet
amendement propose en eff effit
d'autoriser le recrutement par voie
contractuelle d'agents handicapés dans
les administrations des assemblées
parlementaires pouvant donner lieu à
leur titularisation il étant à ses
agents les dispositions du décret du 25
août 1995 applicable à la fonction
publique de l'État celle-ci prévoit
cette titularisation dans le corps de
recrutement si les Agen sont déclarés
aptes à exercer les fonctions au vu de
leur dossier et après un entretien avec
un jury organisé par l'administration
chargée du recrutement lors de sa
titularisation la agent est affecté dans
l'emploi pour lequel il a été recruté
comme agent non titulaire cette
disposition relève donc comme je l'ai
indiqué du statut des fonctionnaires des
assemblé qui pour préserver l'autonomie
des assemblées est fixé par leur bureau
et effectivement c'est la raison pour
laquelle il semblait nécessaire de ne
pas s'éloigner de ce statut considérant
que sur le volet de l'application des
dispositions de la loi 2005 notre
assemblée mais là je parle devant les
les collègues membres du bureau
notamment les questesteurs de
dispositions qui sont mises en œuvre à
ma connaissance
avec des mesures qui vont au moins à la
hauteur des préconisations de la loi si
ce n'est des dispositions plus
avantageuse de façon que la loi de 2005
sur le handicap soit largement prise en
compte dans en pour les personnels de
notre assemblée voilà les les les
observations pour lesquelles j'aurais
souhaité que cet amendement au bénéfice
de ces explications puissent bénéficier
d'un retrait de la part des auteurs et
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement remercie le président de la
commission des lois qui l'a informé de
cet amendement il s'en remet au titre de
la séparation des pouvoirs à la sagesse
du Sénat
madame attend madame Marie- Thérèse herb
je puis monsieur le cestter
garec chers collègues il se trouve qu'il
y a 15 jours nous avons eu un débat sur
le handicap pour valider le contrôle
l'application de la loi de 2005 que nous
avons voté je suis intervenu à cette
tribune et pour faire mon exposé j'ai
bien évidemment d'abord demandé au
service du Sénat au service
administratif du Sénat de voir comment
effectivement notre loi était appliquée
et je me suis aperçu que le Sénat a fait
un point le 16
décembre 2009 ou le 16 janvier 2010 pour
voir pour voir comment notre loi est
appliquée et je voudrais indiquer à à
nos collègues
que le Sénat a prévu un certain nombre
de mesures dérogatoires pour accéder en
tout cas aux fonctions euh de
d'administrateurs de fonctionnaires en
fait du du Sénat et deuxièmement qu'il
prévoit que dans certains cas des
possibilités de
reclassement sont possibles en raison du
handicap de tel ou tel mais que après
consultation du médecin du Sénat et de
la assistante sociale du Sénat certains
préfèrent ne pas être reclassé le
médecin du Sénat indiquer que
quelquefois cela peut être considéré par
tel ou tel agent comme une double peine
donc je crois qu'en tout cas suite au
débat que nous avons eu pour valider le
contrôle l'application de cette loi et
après les interrogation que j'ai eu
auprès des services administratifs ça me
semblait tout à fait normal que parlant
de la du contrôle
handicapir comment notre
assemblée mesur et pratiquer en fait
cette loi je pense que le bureau du
Sénat va continuer à à essayer de de
l'appliquer au mieux et que le bureau et
les questeurs seront sensibles aux
questions que vous posez mais qui sont
déjà un premier pas par le Bureau du
Sénat bien monsieur
le
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je voulais intervenir mais
tout est dit je remercie ma ma collègue
madame herbanche de la qualité de ce
rapport j'aurais dû sansout je l'aurais
fait moins bien effectivement nous avons
nous avons nous avons chercher à
appliquer les textes à notre mieux nous
avons adapté les concours par exemple
les l'épreuve physique qui qui pour
certains peut-être une impossibilité
mais nous l'avons supprimé lorsque
leicable exigeait mais il est vrai que
nous avons aussi un problème avec les
gens de la maison
certains une partie du personnel qui qui
a des handicap léger voir un peu plus
lourd ne ne veulent pas le dire parce
qu'ils ont l'impression que ça serait
une CI diminution que ça les ferait
apparaître quelque part comme moins bien
que leurs collègues donc je crois que
nous avons fait un effort pour cela et
ce qui me gêne dans l'amendement de
notre collègue c'est que la règle de la
maison c'est le concours alors là nous
nous trouvons dev un système qui
consistait à prendre un contractuel à
conserver une année à le titulariser
Eton non euh nous adaptons le concours
pour le faciliter pour les handicapés il
c'est fait c'est en cours ça sera
amélioré en tant que de besoin mais je
crois que nous ne pouvons pas accepter
autre chose que ce concours qui est la
règle normale de du Règlement du
Sénat bon monsieur Maas
oui
oui très franchement mes chers collègues
je ne me peux pas m'imaginer un seul
instant que le Sénat et l'Assemblée
national ne respecteraiit pas la loi
même s'ils ont une autonomie
gestion je ne peux pas m'imaginer cela
alors je vois les explications quelque
peu en
barlificoté à droite bien sûr bien sûr
hein oui on va tout faire pour mais la
règle c'est le
concours le concours adapté on l'a
adapté pour les épreuves physiques bon
il y a pas que ça enfin je veux dire je
veux dire très très Franch
ement il y a une réflexion générale à
voir et il me semble que il n'est pas
possible que nous infraignions la
loi alors toutefois le
rapporteur notre rapporteur a bien
précisé que des efforts sont
fait que un état
d'esprit qui tente un petit peu ramener
un petit peu plus
d'humanisme vis-à-vis des handicapés et
et pratiquer par le bureaux tant mieux
tant mieux alors moi je je veux je veux
bien au bénéfice du doute
m'abstenir à condition à la condition
expresse que il y ait un rendu au bureau
alors ce qui est vrai pour le Sénat
j'aimerais bien aussi qu'il soit vrai
pour l'assemblée parce que et là nous
nous nous je ne sais pas comment
intervenir je ne sais pas si notre le
ministre peut être notre messager c'est
difficile bien évidemment dans dans le
cadre de de la séparation des pouvoirs
je ne sais pas si notre rapporteur ou
notre président de la commission des
lois peut rentrer en rapport avec son
hologue il pourrait être être indiqué au
cours d'une commission de la Commission
paritaire et que c'est dans le même état
d'esprit et à ce moment-là bien
évidemment tout le monde serait
satisfait mais mais très très
franchement je vous vois disons hésitant
et j'en suis très étonné alors madame
matard vous maintenez votre amendement
allez monsieur monsieur gareg bien
sûr je je m'étais dit que j'allais faire
gagner en ne répondant pas à mon ami
Mayas mais j'aimerais que que mes propos
ne soi pas quand je prends un exemple ça
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas l'ensemble
d'une réflexion quand je dis par exemple
le sport bon il y en a d'autres il y a
l'adaptation du travail l'adaptation des
PO de travail tout est envisagé et je
voulais simplement dire qu'on vient
faireer le message que le prochain la
prochaine réunion du du CHS sera lieu le
11 juin et ser consacré en grand partie
au handicap donc c'est la réponse la
question mon cher collègue
bon allez si plus personne ne demande la
parole je mets au voix l'amendement de
madameon PO que ceux qui sont d'avis
adopt ve bien le manifester en levant la
main merci Madame avis contraire et
abstention c'est noté aussi l'amendement
n'est pas adopté allez on
poursuit après à l'article
10 un
amendement de Madame
Laborde 4 rectifié merci monsieur le
Président le présent amendement a pour
objet de rétablir le parétarisme et oui
je suis désolée que le projet de loi
supprime dans les instances de
concertation de la fonction publique le
locale cette suppression qui n'est pas
actée par l'accord de Bery est une
nouvelle défiance adressée au
collectivité territoriale dans le
contexte déjà très difficile de la
réforme des collectivités locales contre
laquelle une majorité d'entre elles
s'est dressé l'ensemble de ces
dispositions ne vise donc en rien
d'autre qu'à ôter un pouvoir aux élus
locaux par méfiance envers eux n'est-ce
pourtant pas le président de la
République qui s'adressant au Congrès
des mares le 27 novembre 2008 déclarait
qu'il fallait mettre un terme à la
situation des employeurs territoriaux
auxquels on ne demande jamais leur avis
en la matière l'unification des régimes
de la fonction publique d'État et de la
fonction publique territoriale est
d'autant plus surprenante et
inacceptable que chacune d'elles relève
de problématiques différentes qui ont
justifié la mise en place de régimes
différenciés or la fonction publique
territoriale regroupe près de 56000
employeurs différents pour autant de
situations qui nécessitent leur
représentation au sein des instances de
négociation la suppression du
paritarisme risque paradoxalement de
remettre en cause la qualité du dialogue
social qui est justement la finalité du
texte votre gouvernement effectue un
périlleux grand écart en voulant d'un
côté faire évoluer la composition des
instances paritaires et de modernisation
du dialogue social et de l'autre limiter
le rôle des employeurs publics
territoriaux dans les comités techniques
paritaires locaux voués à perdre leur
pai ainsi qu'au Conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique territoriale il est
d'ailleurs particulièrement significatif
que le Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale a émis le 199
novembre 2008 un avis unanimement
défavorable sur ce projet de loi
dénonçant la volonté de reprise en main
forte de l'État un néojacobinisme une
recentralisation et la défiance de
l'État à l'égard des élus locaux cette
position a même reçu le soutien de
Jacques Pélissard président de laamf la
suppression du paritarisme dans la
fonction publique territoriale constitue
une nouvelle attaque en règle contre
l'autonomie des collectivités
territoriales que nous entendons dénoncé
je vous remercie euh il y a un
amendement identique de Monsieur Maas il
est défendu par Madame
labord et nous n'avons pas fait de
scrutin public mais nous demandons sur
le territorial un scrutin
public alors attendez il y en a encore
un deux même en discussion commune alors
le 67 de madame
matoana monsieur le Président bon sur le
paritarisme j'y reviendrai pas je pense
que nous l'avons déjà dit et
redit par contre le dialogue qui qui
suppose être équilibré dès lors que les
sièges sont répartis de manière
paritaire entre les les collèges
employeurs et fonctionnaires mais il y a
surtout l'instauration d'un avis
collectif de tous les représentants nous
paraît nécessaire pour que les
négociations soient constructive donc
voter d'une seule voix impose qu'on
recherche tout de même le consensus
alors qu'un votre collège par collège
stigmatise plutôt les oppositions donc
prévoir une seconde délibération en cas
de position négative unanime nous paraît
nécessaire pour éviter un certain nombre
de brocages et il s'agit de favoriser le
consensus même si quand même souvent le
rappeler monsieur ver à l'issue des
négociations c'est à l'administration de
décider mais enfin nous demandons donc
de voter avec nous cette modification
sur l'article 10 alors merci
madameampoana sur l'amendement 18 il
n'est pas défendu tombe alors monsieur
le rapporteur votre avis sur les trois
amendements oui monsieur Président je
vais pas vous surprendre en disant que
c'est un avis défavorable sur ces trois
amendements qui reprennent tous
effectivement le débat sur le
paritarisme et du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre avis défavorable sur les
trois amendements pour des raisons que
j'ai eu l'occasion d'expliquer plusieurs
fois bien alors si je suis saisi c'est
sur l'article a demande de scrutin ah
c'est sur l'article que vous demandez
une demande de scrutin public oui
l'article 10 alors oui donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors continue VO sur les
alors on vote sur cela oui oui alors on
vote d'abord sur les deux amendements le
4 rectifié et le 31
euh d'abord de Madame Laborde et de
Monsieur Maas que ceux qui sont Davis
adopter Paro ah explication de vote
monsieur
deel moi j'aimerais comprendre monsieur
le Président merci de me demander la
parole monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues moi je voudrais bien
comprendre jusqu'à maintenant le Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale est composé de 20 membres
et 20 membres représentant les
collectivités et 20 membres représentant
les syndicats euh comment sont élus et
qui détermine le nombre c'est un décret
qui détermine que il y a tant de
représentants de commune de plus de
20000 tant de représentants de communes
de moins de 200000 de Conseils Général
de des conseils généraux et conseils
régionaux moi je voudrais savoir
Monsieur le Ministre comment ça va se
passer est-ce que on va décider qu'il y
a 20 membres de fois 20 membres est-ce
que il y aura des élections est-ce que
on va constituer des listes de 30 40
membres ou de 10 membres moi je voudrais
savoir comment cela va
s'articuler et avant de voter j'aimerait
bien avir la réponse de Monsieur le
Ministre j'espère d'être bien fait
comprendre euh je vois que le ministre
est en train de lui
expliquer donc je je pense monsieur le
ministre va être bien fait comprendre
actuellement c'est clair il y a tant de
membres de représentant les communes et
cetera alors là comment ça va se passer
parce que pour le reste je comprends
qu'on puisse décider que il est
paritaire ou non mais là s'il n'est pas
paritaire qui va déterminer le nombre et
qui va dire dans quelles conditions vont
se dérouler les élections pour désigner
ces membres des
collectivités monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez donner quelques explications
oui pour les droit au but il n'y aura
pas de changement sauf si le président
du Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territorial demande qu'on
modifie le par décret cette composition
mais on est dans la même logique que
précédemment pas de
changement si plus personne ne demande
la parole je mets au voix les
amendements 4 rectifiés de madame
laabord des 31 de Monsieur Mayas voie
que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter
veuillez bien le manifester en levant la
main
merci avis
contraire merci aussi les amendements
sont pas adoptés celui de Madame Moon
maton
poign he il y a les qu'est-ce que
cherche monsieur demiselle pardon on est
en de voter ben allez vous oublier les
de le président et
porteur
merci merci allez monsieur domiselle je
mets au voix l'amendement de Madame
maton po que ceux qui sont Dav d'adopté
vez bien le manifester la main merci
avis contraire ah c'est bien clair
monsieur demoiselle allons l'amendement
n'est pas adopté alors on va voter sur
l'article 10 comme Monsieur Mayas le
demander au scrutin public alors puisque
nous sommes saisis d'une demande du
groupe
socialiste il va être procédé au scrutin
dans les conditions de l'article 56 du
règlement ce qui souhaitent voter pour
mettrons un bulletin blanc ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre un bulletin bleu
et ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir un
bulletin rouge
allez sur l'article là
c'est
prêt allez ben le scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à voter allez le
scrutin est clos et j'invite Mesdames et
Messieurs les secrétaires à venir
procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
Marseille
ah
ouies
le résultat du scrutin mes chers
collègues sur l'article 10 du projet de
loi relatif au dialogue social dans la
fonction publique nombre de votants
338 nombre de suffrages exprimés
338 majorité absolue des chiffrages
exprimés
170 pour l'adoption
185 contre
153 le Sénat a adopté allez nous en
arrivant à l'article
11 de Madame
àaborde c'est le 5 rectifié madame la ou
tout à fait le présent amendement a pour
objet de rétablir le caractère collectif
rendu par le
CSFPT en lieu et place des délibérations
collège par collège qu'institue
l'article 11 N nous voulons ainsi
préserver l'une des caractéristiques du
dialogue social qui a fait ses preuves
jusqu'à présent au contraire le
dispositif de l'article 11 risque de
briser le modus vivindit qui associe
représentant des employeurs et des
salariés de surcroix le CSFPT est amené
à traiter des sujets particulièrement
importants comme l'évolution de l'emploi
public ou la formation continue qui
justifie la recherche du consensus comme
c'est aujourd'hui le cas la qualité du
travail du CSFPT a toujours été salué
notamment s'agissant des avis qu'il a
rendu sur l'élaboration des textes il
faut d'ailleurs rappeler que la loi du
19 février 2007 relative à la fonction
publique territoriale avait reconnu aux
représentants des collectivités locales
siégeant au CSFPT une fonction de
représentation collective des employeurs
publics locaux de plus il est constant
dans la jurisprudence administrative que
l'avis d'un organe consultatif soit
obligatoirement collégial N nous
refusons dès lors que le CSFPT soit
affaibli par sa division et qu'il ne
devienne ainsi qu'une instance
secondaire je vous remercie et le 68
madame bâon poin
oui monsieur le Président en fait avec
cet article les avis du Conseil seront
rendus collège par collège et non plus
collectivement donc cette décision
suscite quand même l'incompréhension de
nombreux élus territoriaux hein de
droite comme de gauche d'ailleurs euh en
effet séparément les avis des
représentants des employeurs et des
syndicats on risque de briser une
entente quelque peu cordiale qui
fonctionnait bien jusqu'ici donc les
employeurs territoriaux euh et et le
pluralisme qui en coule fonctionne quand
même démocratiquement étant donné
l'importance des enjeux discutés au sein
de ces instances l'évolution de l'emploi
public notamment les élus leur présence
syndicaux devrai agir en synergie ou
tout au moins s'efforcer de dégager des
positions communes dansintérêt du
service
public voilà euh l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur oui le projet de loi institue
l'adoption de l'avis du ccfpt par
collège séparé personnel et employeurs
l'amendement propose de revenir au vote
collectif la Commission a retenu le
système proposé par le gouvernement qui
prévoit l'expression des employeurs
territoriaux comme des agents chacun
pouvant prendre clairement position sur
ssier soumis à la consultation du du
conseil en raison de cette participation
des deux collèges à l'établissement de
la vie rendu par le CSFPT l'AVE est donc
défavorable idem pour l'amendement 68 et
du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
l'avis du Gouvernement est défavorable
l'organisation des votes en collège ça
permet de de structurer qualitativement
si j'ose dire les positions des membres
de l'instance en fait c'est un facteur
de transparence et donc par définition
l' vie est défavorable plus personne
demand la parole mes chers collègues
dans ce cas-là je mets au voix
l'amendement
sincretifié de notre collègue madame
Laborde que ce et le 68 en même temps de
Madame maton poin que ceux qui sont dis
d'adopt veillez bien le manifester en
levant la main merci avis
contraire allez les amendements ne sont
pas adoptés alors nous arrivons un
amendement de Monsieur de Monsieur Mayas
le 32 oui c'est la même chose SAU qu'on
est un peu moins gourmand on demande que
la suppression du 1 et du 2 parce que le
3 N aucun intérêt et donc c'est un
amendement de cohérence monsieur le
Président qui rappelle qu'il n'y a pas
de dialogue si l'avis du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territorial n'est pas rendu
collectivement voilà quel est l'avis de
monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est le même objet que l'amendement
précédent 68 c'est un avis défavorable
et du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
même analyse que le rapporteur et même
conclusion monsieur le Président très
bien plus personne ne demande la parole
allez je mets au voix l'amendement 32 de
notre collègue monsieur Maas que ceux
qui sont d'avis d'adopter veuille bien
le manifester en levant la main merci
avis contraire allez l'amendement n'est
pas adopté et l'article 11
est pas n'est pas modifié je le m au
voix il y a pas d'opposition adopté
l'article 12 aussi d'ailleurs s'il n'y a
pas d' S N a pas d'opposition nous
l'adoptons l'article
13 alors
madame est
défenduz l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur quand
mêmeforable pour tout à l'heure et le
gouvernement aussi Monsieur le Ministre
d'accord même vote que les précéd
madame dans la catégorie pas de chance
ce soir allez pas de chance
si souvent
souvent allez n vous passons une grande
discussion commune là le 6 rectifié de
Madame Laborde je vais vous faire
plaisir il est défendu et le 33 de
Monsieur aussi
oh et le 69 de
madameard pareil et celui de Monsieur de
Golfier ben il
tombe
7 alors où il est le 71 je l'ai pas vu
il sont là ah VO très bien alors 71
encore de Madame maton po défendu aussi
allez et le 34 de Monsieur Mayas non
parler alors là vous voulez parler
hein bien alors c'est ce cet amendement
c'est un amendment de repli vous l'avez
vu je propose d'aller un peu plus loin
que ce que propose le texte actuel en
supprimant les mot si une délibération
le prévoit le texte se lit ainsi l'avis
du comité technique est rendu lorsqu'ils
ont été recueillis d'une part l'avis des
représentant du personnel et d'autre
part l'avis des représentants de la
collectivité ou de l'établissement
certes il s'agit d'un amendement de
repli car nous souhaitons que le
parétarisme soit intégralement maintenu
c'est-à-dire que les voix différentses
les voix des différents collèges
puissent s'additionner cependant si nos
amendements sont pas retenus il faut
prévoir que l'avis des représentants de
la collectivité ou de l'établissement
soit systématiquement recueilli je pense
que cette demande ne posera pas de
difficulté alors monsieur le rapporteur
nous reprenons par le 6 rectifié et les
autres
oui par coordination effectivement tous
les amendements numéro 6 33
69 71 sont un avis défavorable idem
également en ce qui concerne
l'amendement 34 et il s'agit
effectivement concernant les comités
techniques de la fonction publique
territoriale le droit de vote des
représentants de l'employeur dans tous
les cas pour les motifs exprimés à
l'amendement 71 c'est un avis
défavorable
le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre même avis que la commission
monsieur le Président sur le 6 le 33 le
69 et le 71 le 34 vous l'avez appelé
aussi
oui alors je peux y répondre oui avant
le avant le le rapporteur l' c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur Mayas
l'amandon du paritarisme c'est un des
points importants des accords de berc
alors à l'Assemblée nationale le
rapporteur a permis d'assouplir la loi
je l'ai rappelé il y a quelques minutes
en ce qui concerne la fonction publique
territoriale en permettant aux
collectivités qui le souhaitent de
maintenir le vote des employers au
comité technique et je veux pas établir
une obligation le gouvernement a ouvert
une faculté aux élus employeurs dans le
cadre de la libre administration de leur
collectivité plus personne ne demande la
parole mes chers collègues alors dans ce
cas-là je mets au voix dans l'ordre le 6
rectifié et le 33 que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopté veuillez bien le
manifester en levant la
main avis contraire allez ça n'est pas
adopté le
69 de Madame maton Po et le 71 que ceux
qui sont Davis d'adopté veuillez bien le
manifester en levant la main merci avis
contraire pas adopté et le 34 de
Monsieur
Maas même
vote allez on le fait va que ceux qui
sont dis d'adopté veille bien le
manifestant en levant la
main avis contraire
Marie
thérè voilà très bien
allez et nous votons sur l'article 13
alors que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter
veuilleent bien le manifester en levant
la
main avis
contraire il y a pas d'avis contraire
l'article 13 est adopté nous en arrivons
à l'article
avec un amend
rectifié toujours de Madame
Laborde c'est encore un amendement de
cohérence donc je vous fais grâce les
argument nous poursuivons par le
35 monsieur
Maas très bien 72
madame
pareil et encore un rectifié de Madame
Laborde ah oui mais là argument aussi le
présent amendement vise à supprimer la
rédaction trop imprécise du 10e alinéa
de cet article autant nous sommes
ouverts à permettre la consultation du
comité technique sur des questions
d'ordre budgétaire mettant en G en cause
la gestion de l'emploi autant nous
estimons que la rédaction retenue par la
commission est très vague concrètement
comment définir les incidences des
principales décisions à caractère
budgétaire sur la gestion des emplois
nous craignons que l'ambiguïé de cette
disposition ne soit prétexte à de purs
jugement d'opportunités qui conduiraiit
à des traitement différenciés dans
l'ensemble des
collectivités de plus cette imprécision
est porteuse de divergence
d'interprétation qui ouvriront la voie
de multiples contentieux que nous
souhaitons prévenir en demandant la
suppression de cet alinéa je vous
remercie merci merci Madame lebord alors
d'abord s' a l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur les trois
premiers puis sur celui de Madame
Laborde FO madame Laborde d'abord oui
concernant les amendements 7 35 72 sont
des avis donc défavorables en ce qui
concerne l'amendement 8 la loi encadré
la compétence du CTP qui sera précisée
par décret cet alinéa doit être maintenu
les personnels doivent pouvoir être
informé dans certaines de certaines
décisions affectant directement
l'organisation et le fonction des
services c'est un avis défavorable ah
bon et du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président sur
les amendements 7 35 et 72 je n'y
reviens pas on s'est déjà expliqué
plusieurs fois je voudrais en revanche
m'adresser plus personnellement madame
labord pour pour lui dire que l'avis du
du Gouvernement est défavorable
évidemment sur cet article cet
amendement pardon et je voudrais sur le
8 et et je voudrais me permettre de dire
à Madame labord que très franchement
c'est un amendement
qui comment pourrais-je dire est
totalement contraire à l'esprit de des
accords de bersk et qui plus est j'en
suis convaincu qu' viserait à aller dans
une direction qui est certainement
inverse à ce que vous souhaitez
vous-même madame en réalité il s'agit
tout simplement si on suit sa logique à
cette
amendement de faire en sorte de
séparer les questions qui sont d'ordre
budgétaire de tout le reste et on
aboutirait en quelque sorte à ce que on
puisse discuter dans les instances de
l'action sociale du handicap de
l'insertion en général et en revanche
tout ce qui aurait trait euh à l'impact
sur la gestion des emplois des
principales décisions à caractère
budgétaire soit retiré et pour en avoir
discuté avec les syndicats comme le
rapporteur l'a fait comme le président
l'a fait je puis vous assurer que très
franchement ils sont très surpris de de
cet amendement donc en gros pour aller
droit droit au but il s'agit comme vous
l'avez compris de conforter la
compétence des comités techniques à la
fois sur les conditions de travail sur
l'organisation du travail et sur la
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et je
crois très franchement que cet
amendement pourrait être retiré
plus personne ne demande la parole mes
chers collègues madame labord vous
souhaitez aller dans le sens de Monsieur
le Ministre très bien alors je mets au
voix les trois premiers 7 rectifiés 3572
que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopt veuille
bien le manifester en levant la main
merci avis
contraire merci aussi ça n'est pas
adopté alors et l'article non il y a
encore
derrière
un amendement 106 mais de Madame Gouro
personne ne le défend la commission
reprend la Commission le reprend
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois oui monsieur le Président mais
on avait demandé à Madame gourau de le
rectifier puisque en fait il s'agissait
de la consultation des comités
paritaires sur les aides à la protection
sociale complémentaire mais elle a mal
situé son amendement il faut dire aussi
ainsi que sur l'action sociale lorsque
la collectivité territoriale ou
l'établissement public on a décidé
l'attribution à ses agents c'était
l'amendement qui avait été approuvé par
la commission ce matin donc extension à
l'action sociale de la consultation du
comité paritaire comme on le fait pour
la protection sociale complémentaire je
pense que c'est tout à fait légitime
euh monsieur le rapporteur pas
deexlication complémentaire le président
vient de le faire monsieur le ministre
avis de la du gouvernement il est
favorable en fonction des explications
que vient d'apporter le président très
bien s'il n'y a pas de demande
d'explication de vote dans ce cas-là je
mets au voix euh l'amendement
106 alors 106 rectifié 11 ça devient
119 l'amendement 119 de Madame Gouro
c'est bien ça de la Commission de la
Commission de la commission allez OK
dans ce cas-là je mets au voix que ceux
qui sont d'IS d'adopt veuilleent bien le
manifest levant la
main tout le monde quoi avis contraire
il n'y a pas d'avis contraire allez et
l'article
14 je leets au voix que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopter l'article 14 ve bien
manifester la main merci avis
contraire la article 14 est adopté
article 14 bis un amendement de Madame
maton
po
parfait néanmoins il faut que je l'avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
avis défavorable très bien et du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre très
bien pas d'explication de vote je mets
au voix l'amendement de Madame maton
poin que ceux qui sont davisadopté ve
bien manifesterir la main merci avis
contraire allez l'amendement n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 14 B
pas d'opposition je consulte du regard
la Haute Assemblée adopté l'article 14
de Madame maton
po
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable défavorable et le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
défavorable aussi pas d'explication
allez je met au voix l'amendement 74 de
madameon PO ceux qui sont Dav adopté
bien manifester la main merci avis
contraire allez l'amendement n'est pas
adopté décidé un amendement 75 madame
maton
poina il est également défendu monsieur
le le président puisqu'il s'agit de la
vie collective que j'ai demandé tout à
l'heure qui devrait être recueilli là
aussi au sein du du comité d'hygiène de
sécurité des conditions de
travail euh monsieur le rapporteur quel
est l'avis de la commission cohérence
défavorable et du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre aussi
alors il y a un 36 aussi en discussion
commune monsieur Maas
oui je voudrais une précision là parce
que disons le le paritarisme n'est pas
absent de la fonction publique
hospitalière le Conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique hospitalien et
aujourd'hui paritaire d'accord l'article
37 du décret je sais plus la la date du
10 juin 1985 rotative à l'hygiène et à
la sécurité du travail dans la fonction
publique territoriale prévoit le Paris
au sein des comités d'hygiène et de
sécurité nous souhaitons que ce
paritarisme
perdure je pense que ce serait bien
alors quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur avis défavorable
et du gouvernement aussi madame la
ministre défavorable allez je mets au
voix les deux amendements que ceux qui
sont d'avadopté ve bien le manifester en
levir la main merci avis contraire merci
aussi il ne sont pas adoptés l'article
14 terre je mets au voie que ceux qui
sont d'avis de voter l'article 14 ter
bien le manifester en lant la main merci
avis contraire il n'y a pas d'avis
contraire l'article 14 ter est adopté
après à l'article 15 un amendement ne9
rectifié de Madame à La Borde c'est un
amendement de cohérence qui est
défendu avis de la commission de la
Commission défavorable et du
gouvernement aussi Monsieur le Ministre
défavorable je mets au voix l'amendement
9 rectifié de notre collègue madame
Laborde que ceux qui sont d'IS d'adopté
veille bien manifester en levant la main
avis contraire allez l'amendement n'est
pas adopté il en est ainsi décidé nous
poursuivons par un amendement 37 de
Monsieur
maasisme dans la fonction publique
territoriale vous connaissez notre je
pense qu'elle n'a pas changé
et je fiche mon billet que on sera
majoritaire dans les communes
significatif pas évidemment celle où il
y a deux trois employés mais dès qu'il y
aura une centaine
d'employés effectivement ce sera notre
position qui sera celle des Mair
raisonnables bien ils sont tous
d'ailleurs raisonnable
madame
aussi
et le 117 alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous nous donnez l'avis votre avis sur
les deux précédents amendements et vous
nous expliquez le
117 oui c'est un avis défavorable sur
les amendements 37 et 76 sur le
paritarisme en ce qui concerneamendement
117 il s'agit d'une harmonisation de
l'appellation des comité technique par
coordination avec les articles 13 et 14
B l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre voilà très bien alors dans ce
cas-là je mets s'il n'y a pas
d'explication de vote je mets au voix
l'amendement 37 d'abord de monsieur
maeas puis 76 de Madame maton poin que
ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopté veuillez
bien le manifester en levant la main
merci avis contraire allez l'amendement
les amendements ne sont pas adoptés et
l'amendement de monsieur le
rapporteur qui sont d'avis d'adopté
veuille bien le
manifester merci avis contraire il n'y a
pas d'avis contraire l'amendement est
adopté l'article 15 aussi je consulte du
regard la haute assemblée par
d'opposition adopté 15 bis la même chose
même vote même vote il en est ainsi
décidé après l'article 15
bis et ben le numéro 3 là il
tombe
allez après nous en arrivons à l'article
à l'article 16 par une amendement 20 qui
n'est pas
défendu
et l'article 16 je le mets au voix que
ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopté veu bien
le manifesterir la main merci avis
contraire il n'y a pas d'avis contraire
l'amendement est adopté article 17 allez
euh c'est le 108 le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre c'est Madame ah
madame la ministre et oui c'est un un
amendement que je propose pour réparer
un oubli que j'avais fait dans le cadre
de la loi du 21 juillet dernier Hôpital
Patient Santé territoire puisque vous le
savez les carrières des personnels de la
FPH sont géré soit en commission
administrative paritaire locale sont en
commission administrative paritaire
départementale et le niveau
départemental est requis lorsque que le
nombre d'argent du corps est insuffisant
dans l'établissement d'origine pour
constituer une CAPL les CAPD sont donc
régulièrement réunis pour se prononcer
sur les carrières des établissements de
petite taille qui sont très nombreux
vous le savez alors maintenant la
gestion de ces capapd qui incombait
auparavant audace a été donc confié à un
établissement de santé de ce même
département cet amendement vise à
compléter d'un point de vue technique
cette disposition la désignation des
représentants d'administration siégeant
en CAPD est confié non plus au directeur
de la DAS mais très logiquement au
directeur de cet établissement support
c'est donc un un amendement purement
technique et l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
oui cet amendement tire les conséquences
de la loi
hpsst qui a confié la gestion des CAP
départementales à un établissement
public de santé don le siège se trouve
dans le département et non plusautorité
compétente de l'État l'amendement
prévoit donc de confier logiquement au
directeur de cet établissement le soin
de désigner les représentants
d'administration à la CAP c'est un
avisfvorable et du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre madame la ministre oui
excusez-moi elle vient de l'exliquer oh
je suis troublé je suis troublé par
Madame Roseline bachel mais c'est pas la
première
foisoire a-t-il y y a-t-il des
explications de vote mes chers collègues
non dans ce cas-là je mets au voix
l'amendement 108 de madame la ministre
que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter veent
bien le manifester en levant la main
merci avis contraire il n'y a pas d'avis
contraire l'amendement est adopté
l'article 17 aussi à l'article 18 un
amendement 77 de Madame
maton oh
superbe de la la commission même
cohérence défavorable et du gouvernement
madame la
ministre défavorable très bien dans ce
caslà je m au voix l'amendement de
Madame maton poin que ceux qui sontis
d'adopté veuille bien le manifester en
avir la main merci avis
contraire allez l'amendement n'est pas
adopté et l'article 18 je mets au voix
l'article 18 que ceux qui sont Davis
d'adopter veuillez bien le manifester en
levant la main merci avis contraire il
n'y a pas d'avis contraire il en est
ainsi décidé l'article 19 pas
d'amendement je consulte du regard la
Haute Assemblée même vote même vote pour
l'article 20 est la même chose et pour
l'article 21 pareil il en est ainsi
décidé allez à l'article 21 bis madame
matompoana en fait c'est une chose pe
coutume parce qu'on supprime cet article
pour en fait revenir aux dispositions de
la loi de juillet 2009 qui prévoit que
dans les ARS et les CTP aux compétences
adaptées pour tenir compte de la
présence des salariés de droit privé de
sorte que droit privé et droit public
puissent avoir à la
fois les mêmes
compétences alors que dit le
rapporteur
l'article 21 bis renforce la
représentation de l'ensemble des agents
ARS au sein des organismes consultatifs
qui sont institués en tenant compte la
multitude du statut de droit public ou
privé coexistant au sein des agences et
leur étend les modifications introduire
dans les statuts des trois fonctions
publiques je rappelle que les agences
emploi des personnels relevants de
différentes catégories fonctionnaires
des trois versant pracien hospitalier
contractuel de droit public agent de
droit privé régis par les conventions
des organismes de sécurité sociale
l'amendement revient sur l'avancée
réalisée par l'article 21 bis c'est un
avis défavorable et du gouvernement
madame la ministre
oui je je suis un peu surprise de voir
cet amendement venir des membres du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
et des sénateurs du Parti de gauche
parce que justement il devrait plutôt se
rallier à la nouvelle rédaction que je
propose puisque je veux mieux prendre en
compte les différences de statut des
agents qui travaillent dans les agences
régionales de santé euh nous prévoyons
la création de deux collèges électoraux
l'un pour les agents publics et l'autre
pour les agents de droits privé régies
par les conventions collectives des
organismes de sécurité sociale et je
crois me souvenir précisément que
pendant la discussion votre les membres
de votre groupe étit extrêmement
attachés à ces différences et qui les
ont défendu à juste titre avec beauou
beaucoup de de
pugnacité et ainsi nous allons donner un
fondement législatif à l'adaptation des
règles relatives aux modalités
d'appréciation de la représentativité
syndicale tant pour les élections
professionnelles que pour la négociation
des accords ainsi par décret les
résultats électoraux auront à prendre
pour à prendre en compte pourront être
appréciés par collège et non au niveau
de l'agence comme le droit commun le
prévoit avec cette nouvelle rédaction le
code de la santé publique respectera
mieux la représentation des différentes
catégories de personnels et la création
d'un comité national de concertation
constitue donc une adaptation destinée à
assurer pour l'ensemble des ARS une
représentation de tous les agents de ces
deux collèges je veux préciser que par
ailleurs euh ce dispositif a fait
l'objet de très nombreux échanges avec
les organisations syndicales
représentatives des agents publics d'un
côté et des agents de droits privés
régis par les conventions collectives
des organismes de sécurité sociale et je
pense madame matomo que les explications
que je vous donne et la garantie que je
vous donne également d'une meilleure
prise en compte de la volonté des
personnels devrait peut-être vous amener
à retirer C son votre amendement si vous
ne faisiez pas évidemment je donnerai un
avis
défavorable madame maton poid vous êtes
convaincu par les arguments de Madame le
Ministre
je ne suis pas vraiment convaincu et
puis je pense que c'est un amendement
aussi qui vient de la part de mes
collègues des affaires sociales donc je
je le
maintiens plus de demande d'explication
de vote dans ce caslà je mets au voix
l'amendement 79 de Madame maton po que
ceux qui sont d'IS d'adopt veillent bien
le manifester en levant la main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
et un amendement de monsieur le
rapporteur le
c'est une précision rédactionnelle non
pas d'opposition du gouvernement
j'imagine très
bien je mets au voix pas d'opposition
adopté et pour l'article 21 ben je le
mets au voix que ceux qui sont d'avis
d'adopter l'article 21 veillez bien le
manifester enant la main merci 21 B oui
oui
pardon et avis contraire il y a pas
d'avis contraire il en estsi décidé
allez sur le chapitre 5 pas d'opposition
nous en arrivons à
l'article à l'article 22 un amendement
38 de Monsieur Mayas
oui cet amendement prévoit la validité
d'un accord si signé par une ou
plusieurs organisations syndicales ayant
recueilli au total au moins 30 % du
nombre de voix sous réserve d'une
absence
d'opposition des syndicats majoritaires
en voie bon on s'accrochera pas à cet
amendement si on nous dit que la marche
qui après sera de 50 % après
la le
transitoire sera facile à franchir ou
pas voilà c'est quand même un petit peu
et par rapport au privé c'est un c'est
un petit peu le fouillli quoi non ça
semble on peut faire une suspension de
séance madame le ministre on pas cette
Tardi he monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur euh vous donnez votre avis
oui il s'agit d'un amendement concernant
la période transitoire euh sur
l'alignement des conditions de validité
des accords durant la période
transitoire sur les conditions du droit
du travail l'article 22 a repris les
conditions actées dans les accords de
Bery auquels il convient de se tenir
pour ces motifs c'est un avis
défavorable et du gouvernement madame la
ministre monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le
Président il y a deux bonnes raisons
monsieur Mayas de deémettre un avis
défavorable la première et je suis
certain que vous allez souscrire c'est
qu'en réalité ce choix de 20 % est le
choix issu des accords de ber et en
réalité comme nous vous l'avons dit
plusieurs fois nous souhaitons rester et
vous aussi je le sais dans la logique
des accords qui ont été conclus entre
les organisation avec les organisations
syndicales entre elles l'objet par
ailleurs du seil transitoire c'est de
faciliter la conclusion d'accord dans
une période de changement d'évolution du
dialogue social où il sera nécessaire à
chacun de s'approprier les futures
règles et l'esprit nouveaux qu'elles
implique c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous émettons l'avis
défavorable bien dans ce caslà monsieur
Maras dans ce CASL si vous estimez que
après les 50 % la marche sera pas très
haute je retire mon amendement
l'amendement est retiré je vais mettre
au voix l'article 2 que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopt ve bien manifester en la
main merci avis contraire il n'y a pas
d'avis contraire
laticle 22 plus exactement est adopté
l'article
23 un amendement de Madame
matonard c'est simple monsieur le
Président il s'agit tout simplement par
cet amendement POS simplement le respect
du calendrier qui a été fixé par les
accords de ver monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
oui d'après le système retenu par la
commission les règles transitoires
s'appliquent au premier mandat de
l'instance après la publication de la
loi les règles définitives lors du
premier renouvellement après le 31
décembre 2013 qui marquera la fin de la
périe transitoire c'est donc un avis
défavorable gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
en réalité il serait préférable de
retirer l'amendement sinon ce sera un
avis défavorable tel que rédigé l'alinéa
premier de l'article vise à garantir
qu'au cours du premier mandat du CCFP et
pendant toute la période de ce mandat
les règles prévues par les accords de
ber pour la composition transitoire des
instances supérieures de concertation
s'applique la référence à la Seu date du
31 décembre 2013 pouvait avoir un effet
couê qui fragilisait le mandat de cette
instance alors que évidemment là n'était
pas l'intention des signataires et pour
Cuse des accords de BC aussi il me
semble que nous partageons le même
objectif qui est le respect des
stipulations des accords de BC je l'ai
dit précédemment je le redis ici
s'agissant là en l'occurrence de
l'entrée en vigueur progressive des
nouvelles règles de composition des
instances de concertation madame vous
maintenz votre amendement dans ce cas-là
je le mets au voix que ceux qui sont
décidés de le voter vez bien le
manifester en levant la
main avis contraire l'amendement n'est
pas adopté un amendement gouvernement
109 monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président le
présent amendement a pour objet de
prévoir la prise en compte des résultats
des élections des représentants des
personnels de la Fonction publique au
sein des offices publics de l'habitat
pour la composition du conseil commun de
la fonction publique il n'y a pas lieu
de distinguer en effet la composition de
cette instance entre la période
transitoire et la période pérenne c'est
une disposition qui est favorable bien
sûr aux agents publics et la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur oui c cet amendement améliore
les conditions de représentation du
personnel au Conseil commun pour la
prise en compte des offices publics de
l'habitat c'est un avis
favorable je mets au voix cet amendement
du Gouvernement que ceux qui sont d'avis
d'adopt ve de manifester en levant la
main merci avis contraire il n'y a pas
d'avis contraire l'amendement est adopté
l'article 23 je mets au voix l'article
23 que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopté
veuillez bien le manifester merci avis
contraire il n'y a pas d'avis contraire
l'article arle 23 est adopté à l'article
24 un amendement même 2 de Madame mon
poend très bien merci
madame je mets au voix quand même l'avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
sur le 83orable et du gouvernement
pareil et le
80 même chose bon madame je mets au voix
vos deux amendements que ce qui sont
d'avis d'adopté veillez bien le
manifester merci avis contraire allez
les deux amendements ne sont pas adoptés
nous en arrivons à un amendement 110 du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à clarifier le mode de
composition transitoire du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique de
l'État il s'agit de tenir compte d'une
part de la spécificité de la
cartographie des comité technique au
sein de la nouvelle fonction publique de
l'État et d'autre part de l'entrée en
vigueur progressive des nouvelles règles
de composition de ces instances prévues
par la loi ainsi le prochain
renouvellement du mandat du Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique de
l'État se fera à partir d'instance qui
auront été renouvelé en 2010 selon les
règles anciennes et d'autres qui auront
été renouvelé après la publication de la
loi selon les nouvelles règles prévues à
l'article 8 cela évite bien entendu de
vote avec en réalité aucune raison de le
refaire un vote en si peu de
temps sur une explication de vote on
vous suivrait si si jamais vous nous
donnz une une date du du décret qui est
ici soit l'un des tout premiers décrets
pris très très rapidement hein parce que
véritablement quand on vous demande des
décrets quelquefois il reste dans des
tiroir et pass parfois aux oubliettes et
là c'est une nécessité absolue de
procéder vite monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez répondre à Monsieur Maas oui je
peux dire à Monsieur Maas que le décret
sera pris en septembre et qu'on
travaille d'ors et déjà dus avec les
organisations
syndicales dans ce cas-là je mets au
voix l'amendement du Gouvernement que
ceux qui sont d'avis de voter ve bien le
manifestant devant la main merci avis
contraire il n'y en a pas l'article 24
même vote même vote à l'article
25 madame Tom
poana très bien avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable et du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre aussi
bon madame à ton poinage m au voix votre
amendement 84 que ceux qui sont Dav
adopté ve bien le manifester en levir la
main avec
contraire merci l'amendement n'est pas
adopté si je fais sourire madame à
laaborde c'est que je suis pas venu pour
rien euh bon allez nous en arrivons à un
amendement 39 de Monsieur Maas on va
finir par lui donner un peu satisfaction
monsieur Mayas quand même là vous avez
bon fonctionner à vitesse d'un
TGV je n'ai aucune satisfaction et mon
groupe n'a aucune satisfaction jusqu'à
présent et ce serait étonnant al si vous
me donnez satisfaction sur cet
amendement et bien très franchement je
passé une bonne
nuit alors monsieur le rapporteur il
attends il y a aussi de Madame maton
poin le 91 il est défendu il est défendu
allez monsieur le rapporteur c'est un
avis défavorable sur le 39 et 81 et du
gouvernement
aussi pourtant je fais des efforts hein
monsieur Maas allez dans ce cas-là je
mets au voix et le 39 et le 81 que ceux
qui sont avis d'adopter veuillent bien
le manifester en levant la main merci
avis contraire allez les amendements ne
sont pas adoptés nous en arrivons à un
111 du gouvernement
oui ement c'est la même chose que tout à
l'heure comme le dit très justement le
président le présent amendement a pour
objet de prévoir la prise en compte des
résultats des élections des
représentants des personnels de la
Fonction publique au sein des offices
publicqus de l'habitat pour la
composition du Conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique territoriale il n'y a
pas lieu de distinguer en effet la
composition de cette instance entre la
période transitoire et la période
pérenne et la commission monsieur le
rapporteur oui par cohérence avec
l'amendement tout à l'heure c'est un
avis favorable dans ce cas-là je mets au
voix l'amendement que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopté veille bien manifester
merci en levant la main avis contraire
il n'y a pas d'avis contraire l'article
25 même vote même vote allez nous en
arrivons à l'article 26 madame matomoana
pour le
85 tout à fait et Monsieur Maas pour le
40 ah c'est Monsieur le mê faut laisser
se reposer un peu monsieur Maras et pu
il est frustré sans arrêt là
doncsent oui tout à fait
oui cet amendement vise à faire en sorte
que tous les cadres de direction non
représentés localement puissent l'être
au sein du Conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique hospitalière l'article
2 de la loi du 9 janvier 1986 portant
disposition statutaire relative à la
fonction public hospitalière mentionne
parmi les personnels de direction les
catégories suivantes premièrement les
établissements publics de santé ensuite
les offices publics les maisons de
retraite publique àexclusion de celles
qui sont rattachées au bureau d'êide
sociale de Paris 4rièm les établissement
public ou à caractère public relevant
des services départementaux de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et maisons d'enfants
à caractère social 5èmement les
établissements publics ou à caractère
public pour mineurs ou adultes
handicapés ou inadaptés à l'exception
des établissements nationaux des
établissements d'enseignement ou
d'éducation surveillée 6ièmement les
centre d'hébergement et de réadaptation
sociale publique au caractère public
sepèmement les centres d'accueil et de
soins hospitaliers de Nanterre en en ne
mentionnant que les établissements
publics de santé et centes d'accueil et
de soins hospitaliers de Nanterre le
projet de loi exclut plus de 1000
directeurs il laisse de côté la moitié
des cadres de direction puisque
seulement 3500 directeurs sur un total
de 6000 directeurs issus des trois corps
seraient représentés les directeurs
d'établissements sanitaires sociaux et
médicos-sociaux ainsi que les directeurs
de soins exercent dans les
établissements publics de santé tout
comme les directeurs d'hôpitaux la
discrimination entre ces catégories ne
peut se justifieré même s'il s'agit
d'une disposition transitoire et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous vous
invitons à adopter cette amendement car
il est juste de retenir une rédaction
assurant la représentation de tous les
directeurs l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur les deux
amendements donc sur l'amendement 85
c'est un avis défavorable en ce qui
concerne l'amendement 40 euh cette
période transitoire qui maintient les
équilibre de la situation actuelle telle
qu'elle ressort de l'application du
décret du 13 octobre 88 celui-ci prévoit
en effit qu'un des sièges des
organisations syndicales des
fonctionnaires est attribué à
l'organisation syndicale la plus
représentative des personnels de
direction sur la base des résultats
obtenus aux élections à la CAP nationale
ce siège est attribué aujourd'hui à la
Confédération nationale des cadres
hospitalier c'est donc un avis
défavorable et du gouvernement pour les
deux amendements monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président il est
défavorable pour le 85 en ce qui
concerne le 40 il est défavorable
également parce que cet article présente
en fait des dispositions transitoires
c'est-à-dire des dispositions actuelles
qu'il convient de maintenir pendant une
durée limitée pour permettre les
meilleures conditions de la transition
jusqu'au plus tard le 31 décembre 2013
or la rglement la réglementation
actuelle prévoit qu'un siège soit
attribué à l'organisation syndicale la
plus représentativ des personnels de
direction il n'y a donc pas de raison
que des dispositions à voocation
précisément transitoires modifi à effet
immédiat les modalité de représentation
et pour cette raison on peut souscrire
l'amendement
voilà si plus personne ne demande la
parole je mets au voix l'amendement 85
de Madame maton poin que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopt ve bien la manifester
merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement de Monsieur leemain 40 même
vote même vote j'en arrive à l'article
26 que ceux qui sont d'avis de vootter
l'article 26 veillez bien le manifester
en levant la main merci allez l'article
26 est adopté à l'article
27 un amendement de Monsieur de Monsieur
le ou de Monsieur
Mayas allez monsieur
Maas pardonagit toujours d'un amement de
cohérence visant empêcher l'entrée en
vigueur des dispositions supprimant le
paritarisme quel est l'avis de la
commission pour la même
cohérence je fais celu et le
gouvernement al un amendement du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre vous
donnerz en même temps votre avis sur le
41 s'il vous plaît
oui monsieur le Président donc il esté
favorable pour des raisons de cohérence
en parallélisme des formes si j'ose dire
sur donc le
112 cet amendement vise principalement à
clarifier les modalités d'entrée en
vigueur des nouvelles dispositions
relatives aux commissions administratif
paritaire et au comités technique et au
comités d'hygiène et de sécurité de la
fonction publique de l'État les de et 3e
alinéa permettent ainsi de lever toute
ambigué sur le maintien des règles de
composition prévu par les articles 14 et
15 de la loi du 11 janvier 84 portant
disposition statutaair relative à la
fonction publique de l'État dans sa
rédaction antérieure à la présente loi
pour les instances dont le mandat a été
renouvelé en 2010 ou est en cours de
lettre sur le fondement de ces
dispositions il s'agit en fait de
sécuriser tout simplement juridiquement
le processus de constitution ou de
recomposition des instances en cours au
niveau local comme au niveau national et
donc en cohérence le 4e alinéa vise à
clarifier qui la date d'entrée en
vigueur des nouvelles règles de
composition de ces instances le premier
alinéat enfin corrige par ailleurs une
coquille qui était simplement
rédactionnelle la deuxème phrase du 3i
de l'article est relative à la
commission consultative nationale qui
est mentionnée à l'article 25 et non à
l'article 18 de la loi du 9 janvier
1986 l'avis de la commission sur
l'amendement du Gouvernement monsieur
rapporteur
oui effectivement si il s'agit d'une
clarification des modalités d'entrée en
vigueur des dispositions relatives au
Cap CT CHSCT le premier corrige
effectivement une référence commission
consultative nationale les 2è et 3è
maintiennent expressément les règles de
composition en vigueur pour les
instances renouvelées en 2010 ou en
cours de lettre sur ce fondement et la
4e clarifie la date d'entrée en vigueur
des nouvelles règles de composition des
instances c'est un avis
favorable donc je vais mettre au voix
d'abord l'amendement 41 de Monsieur
Mayas que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter
vez bien le manifester merci avec
contraire merci aussi l'amendement n'est
pas adopté je mets au voix l'amendement
112 du gouvernement que ceux qui sont
David adopté veillez bien le manifester
aussi avis
contraire il n'y a pas d'avis contraire
la l'amendement est adopté l'article 27
aussi l'article 28 m'avez dit on va
jusquà quel numéro bon alors le 42 de
Monsieur Maas
oui monsieur le Président il s'agit d'un
d'un amendement qui vise à maintenir à 6
ans la durée du mandat des instances de
concertation dans la fonction publique
territorial alors je sais que notre
assemblée comprend de nombreux maires et
j'espère qu'ils soutiendront cet
amendement l'article 28 de la version
initiale du projet de loi prévoyait
l'élection simultanée des organismes
consultatif dans la fonction publique à
l'occasion du premier renouvellement de
ces instances la formulation a été
modifié en commission au Sénat mais
cette modification n'a malheureusement
aucun effet sur le fond prévoir la
convergence des élections au lieu d'une
élection simultanée ne résout pas le
problème le vrai problème c'est qu'il
existe un temps propre aux élus des
collectivités territoriale la durée des
moment des mandats varie 3 ans pour la
fonction publique d'État 4 ans pour la
fonction publique hospitalière et
surtout 6 ans dans la fonction publique
territoriale la durée du moment du
mandat dans la fonction territorial
correspond à la nécessité de s'ancrer
dans les territoires on ne peut la
réduire sans affecter la légitimité des
élus faut-il le rappeler un certain
nombre des membres des instances
consultatives ne sont pas issus de la
majorité l'esprit du texte et de
permettre une meilleure représentativité
des organisations syndicales en fondant
la composition des organismes
consultatifs exclusivement sur les
résultats aux élections professionnelles
allons jusqu'au bout faisons primer
cette logique démocratique dans le
respect de la diversité des fonctions
publiques en particulier dans la
fonction publique territoriale chaque
composante tire sa légitimité des
élections ce qui n'est pas le cas à
l'état où les représentants de
l'administration ne sont pas élus mais
désignés par ailleurs l'organisation des
élections professionnelles tous les 4
ans représentera une charge
supplémentaire pour les collectivités
territorial en terme de coût et de
moyens à mobiliser et en plus
politiquement je ne sais pas si c'est
une bonne affaire par rapport au
gouvernement quel qu'il
soit quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
oui il s'agit de la suppression à
disposition permettant l'harmonisation
des cycles électoraux dans les trois
fonctions publiques pour maintenir à 6
ans la durée du mandat des organismes
consultative dans la fonction publique
territoriale la Commission adhérit à la
disposition pragmatique proposée par le
gouvernement qui est effectivement le
choix de 4 années puisque nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec TR trois durées 3 4 et
6 ans effectivement il a été proposé la
la durée de 4 ans comme le faisait
remarquer à l'instant le président de la
commission des lois il y a effectivement
les élections des conseills généraux qui
se font par renouvellement tous les 3
ans et puis il y a également la question
très sincèrement qui qui se débat est-il
vraiment judicieux qu'il y ait
superposition et coïncidence entre le
ren nouvellement pour les cycles
électorauuxx et également le mandat des
organismes consultatifs personnellement
je n'en suis pas convaincu je suis même
convaincu du contraire donc nous en
restons effectivement à l'harmonisation
et la disposition des 4 ans c'est un
avis défavorable et du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre il est également
défavorable l'article favorise
l'harmonisation on l' bien compris de la
durée des mandats de l'ensemble des
instances de concertation dans la
fonction publique avec l'objectif d'un
renouvellement simultané de ces
instances tous les 4 ans euh il s'agit
là et je me permets de de le redire avec
force à Monsieur Mayas d'une stipulation
importante des accords de Bery qui
conforte la place de l'élection comme
fondement d'une meilleure
représentativité et de la légitimité des
organisations syndicales dans la
fonction publique il s'agit également
d'un signal politique et social fort en
terme d'unité de la fonction publique et
qui ne remett en rien en cause les
spécificités de chacune des fonctions
publiques en particulier la légitimité
également tirer des urnes des
représentants des collectivités
territoriales au sein de ces instances
de concertation ainsi je peux me
souscrire à à cet amendement don je
redis que c'est un des éléments forts
des accords de Persie euh plus personne
ne demande la parole monsieur
Maas dans un cas le paritarisme il y a
pas d'unité dans un autre cas il faut
une unité là donc je pense qu'un jour ou
l'autre il faut que le gouvernement
choisisse une ligne directrice nous nous
avons une cohérence c'està dire qu'il
existe des élections dans nos communes
notamment tous les 6 ans il est logique
qu'une qu'une équipe municipal travaille
avec une équipe syndicale qui qui a été
élue pour la pour la même durée ça
m'apparaît pas complètement absurde hein
c'est pas complètement absurde monsieur
le ministre c'est pas complètement
absurde je vous remercie beaucoup de
Maes le pensent aussi je mets au voix
l'amendement de notre collègue Monsieur
Ma que ceux qui sont David adopté veille
bien le manifester merci avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas ad
alors nous en arrivons à un amendement
disrectifié de Madame
Laborde vous nous oubliez toujours les
deux
là
bon allez nous en sommes au 10 rectifié
de Madame
àam alors nous nous ne voulons pas
supprimer l'article mais le modifier
l'accord de ber signé en 2008 par 6
syndicats représentatifs sur 8 prévoit
d'harmoniser la date des élections et la
durée des mandats 4 ans pour les
instances de concertation des trois
fonctions publiques donc à l'heure
actuelle la durée des mandats des
instances représentatives de la fonction
publique territoriale est fixée à 6 ans
ce qui permet de faire coïncider leur
mandat avec celui des élus locaux cette
coïncidence des durées est tout à fait
cohérente dès lors que les employeurs
les élus locaux tirent leur légitimité
d'élection qui ont lieu tous les 6 ans à
l'inverse rien n'empêche de dure cette
période à 4 ans dans la fonction
publique d'État où les représentants de
l'employeur l'État ne sont pas élus mais
désignés rien ne justifie donc
l'harmonisation des régimes de situation
intrinsèquement différent nous rappelons
d'ailleurs que les trois plus grandes
associations d'élus la MF la BF et la RF
se sont déclarés opposés à cette
harmonisation enfin si je peux me
permettre à l'heure où la RGPP sert de
balise unique à l'action gouvernementale
il est de Bonon de rappeler que la
réduction de la la périodicité des
élections professionnelles dans la f PT
excusez-moi engendrera un surcroix non
négligeable pour les
collectivités
alors le 44 de Monsieur demisel
peut-être ou monsieur Maas
toujours il s'agit d'un amendement de
repli si l'amendement visait à supprimer
l'ticle que le 28 n'était pas adopté il
faudrait prévoir d'exclure de
l'harmonisation de la durée des mandats
les instances de concertation de la
fonction publique territoriale bon mais
il
faudrait suppression de l'article
28 soit pas voté
hein alors monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis sur le 10 rectifié et le
44 monsieur Maas
oui sur le 10 rectifié c'est un avis
défavorable mais puisque cette question
de la durée été longuement évoqué très
sincèrement on peut on peut partager des
opinions diamétralement opposé mais je
poserai simplement une question à mes
collègues bon quand on a des équipes qui
se renouvellent on imagine que on peut
peut-être souhaiter cette harmonisation
quand on est en revanche dans le cas
d'équipe nouvelle je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on rende service à une équipe
nouvelle qui prend ses fonctions qui
doit prendre possession du
fonctionnement administratif et quand
quand on voit les difficultés qu'ont les
nouvelles équipes à prendre en charge le
lancement des équipes municipales je ne
crois pas qu'on leur rende service en
leur imposant en plus la superposition
de ce cycle des renouvellements des
représentations syndicales c'est la
raison pour laquelle je crois que la
période de 4 ans et
l'harmonisation est une bonne
proposition en tout cas c'est un avis
défavorable et le même avis défavorable
pour l'amendement 44 et le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
l'avis est défavorable de fois et je
partage pleinement la question qui est
émise par par le rapporteur je soulligne
simplement à nouveau avec force que
notre objectif est d'être dans la
logique des accords qui ont été signés
et que ce dispositif est un des
dispositifs fondamentaux des accords de
Bercy tout à l'heure monsieur Maas avec
beaucoup de talent d'ailleurs a défendu
une position à la tribune qui visait à à
indiquer que nous étions nous-mêmes
reprochables de ne pas suivre les
accords de BC et pardon de le souligner
là mais on s'éloigne urit des accords de
berc qui ont été conclus et donc en
conséquence je suis quand même très
soucieux de redire que c'est une
disposition essentielle des accords de
Bery dans ce cas-là monur monsieur Maas
oui bon vous suivez les accords de Bercy
quand ça vous intéresse ça ça vous ou ça
arrange
et permettez-moi de de de de suivre
aussi l'opinion des représentants des
élus hein quand des associations d'élus
ont une
position ils ont aussi droit à ce que le
gouvernement en tienneent compte en
tienent compte et et et par là même ça a
été
excellemment dit par notre collègue la
position les représentants des élus ne
ne souhait pas cette harmonisation donc
ce sera à vous de trancher mais le jour
où vous rencontrerez ces associations
d'élus vous le dirit bien évidemment
votre avis par rapport au choix que vous
avez fait entre les syndicats et ces
représentations d'élus bon en ce qui
concerne disons notre rapporteur mais
monsieur le rapporteur une des élus qui
viennent d'être élu euh bon il y en a
beaucoup d'abord c'est pas des perdrons
de l'année et puis il y a souvent des
continuités et puis même quand c'est une
nouvelle équipe bah tant mieux tant
mieux je je je crois qu'on redémarre par
parce que avant bah la municipalité
ancienne qui a souvent été minoritaire
se se retrouve avec une une équipe avec
uneologie certainement différente et et
par là même je ne vois aucune difficulté
à ce que les à ce que les relations dans
ces conditions se se trouvent être
détesta ce ce n'est absolument pas mon
opinion
euh monsieur le
ministre non je voulais pas prolonger le
mais cela dit je voulais simplement
faire remarquer monsieur Mayas que c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que
d'avoir des articles additionnels issus
du gouvernement dans un texte qui
contient les accords que d'avoir des
dispositifs qui modifient le contenu des
accords signés par les organisations
syndicales si plus personne ne demande
la parole je mets au voix l'amendement
10 rectifié de Madame Laborde que ceux
qui sont David adopté va bien le
manifester en levant la main merci avis
contraire ça n'est pas AD AD et
l'amendement 44 de Monsieur Maas que
ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter veille
bien manifester en levant la main merci
avis
contraire l'amendement aussi n'est pas
adopté nous en arrivons à un 43 de
Monsieur
Mayas la coordination
coordination très bien monsieur monsieur
le
rapporteur rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur sur le 43 de
Monsieur Ma un amendement de
coordination défavorable par cohérence
bon et du ministre même chose je mets au
vo l'amendement de monsieurux qui sont
adopt bien manifest la main merci
contraire merci aussi ce n'est pas
adopté le gouvernement pour le 113
monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président le
présent amendement a pour objet
d'intégrer les
institionsésenttiv personnel de la
fonction publique dans des organismes
tels que La Poste France Télécom ou les
offices publics de l'habitat dans le
processus de convergence du calendrier
des élections professionnelles en
application des articles 4 6 et 10 les
résultats des élections organisées pour
la désignation des représentants des
personnels au sein de ces institutions
ont vocation à être prise en compte pour
la composition du conseil commun de la
fonction publique du Conseil supérieur
de la fonction publique de l'État et du
Conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale il convient donc
conformément aux accord de berc
d'harmoniser la durée du mandat de ses
instances particulières avec celle des
autres organismes consultatifs de la
fonction publique et l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est un amendement qui intgre des
organismes consultatif la poste français
lesc les offices publics il s'agit
office public de l'habitat il s'agit
donc d'une précision dans ce processus
d'harmonisation des cycles électoraux
c'est un avis favorable alors je mets au
voix l'amendement 113 du gouvernement
que ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopté veuill
bien le manifester enir la main merci
avis contraire il n'y a pas d'avis
contraire l'amendement est adopté
l'article
28 l'article 28 même vote à l'article 29
un amendement de Madame La
Borde c'est toujours un amendement de
cohérence
alors Monsieur lefable par du
gouvernement
aussi
bon même vote allez ça n'est pas adopté
euh sur l'article
45endement 45 l'amendement 45 monsieur
Maas coordination coordination aussi
madame et Madame matonoin
aussi bon je mets au voix les deux
amendements l'avis défavorable
défavorable et aussi du gouvernement
très bien je mets au voix les deux
amendements que qui sont d'avis d'adopté
veuillez bien le manifester en levir la
main merci avis contraire merci aussi
ils ne sont pas adoptés l'article 29 je
mets au voix l'article 29 que ceux qui
sont d'avis d'adopter veuillez bien le
manifester enevant la main merci à vie
contraire il n'y en a pas adopté le 29
bis même vote même vote et ben nous
allonsous en arrêter là et nous
reprendrons la séance nouvelle séance
demain matin à
9h30 nous quittons l'émicycle du Sénat
merci d'avoir suivi cette séance je vous
retrouve cet après-midi pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
rénovation du dialogue social merci de
votre fidélité et bonne journée à tous
sur Public
Sénat